[Music]
because now we are talking about playing
like a pro so let's look at the best pro
which we kept on the chassis and he's
been like a best pro for many a human
before becoming the world champion he
was number one in ello so maybe for I
don't know if for 10 years but around
that and he'll be for quite a few years
because probably in my opinion there
will appear like a young challenger much
younger than him which usually occurs
probably he already is over there
playing and already being like a great
player but probably somebody younger but
I want to show you what I've seen in his
match with Wesley saw which was the
standard which already discussed this
happens to be the third game as I see it
and I'd like to see it you know I'll
tell you that time but I'm putting like
this the training may just not to see
not to see the motion we are trying
together and then after we see this game
we will see from today's a normal player
which plays bits like nothing even
compared because by constants I played
the same the same position but of course
I miss played it and it was like fat but
ok this was really impressive and like I
told you earlier it was really
impressive that he even made an
improvement on his own play although it
finished with different result but still
you know it's something extraordinary so
this was the game which I saw this what
played on control 5 minutes plus 2
seconds but I remember vividly and we
will see to another that it was like you
get like 2 minutes left at the end the
end of the board so ok he likes to play
despite almost every kind of system
because he really plays incredible jet
ski even played here 93 96 95 which of
course sometimes big is difficult to
explain even to the younger players
because normally you tell them you try
to develop it's difficult to explain to
the younger players because you say ok
develop the piece and then you see one
of the best playing 9 395 but
this is a move like mainly because he
wants to talk why a certain type of pawn
structure and he knows so many patterns
so many things about Jason you know so
many type of position what you really
took play and if you don't know you just
like incredible intuition so I've read
like a lot of interviews and I always
you know follow everything about just
I'm quite interested in chess really so
okay I remember one of kids interviews
of Carson he was saying about his work
with Chris borrowing says yes because
parkas helped me a lot and so on and so
on so they talk in this was maybe in two
thousand eleven twelve or thirteen
before he was a world champion but still
was obviously number one yeah we are we
are different but he helped me a lot he
cares like a much wider choice of move
keys looking at so we have a different
style but we have to a certain position
we have to look what move your play
almost always and he was not like
arrogant on Houston hood I'm much more
you know precise to find the right move
in the right plan like much mass fast
dankest power so okay he could read the
type of talent which is incredible so
they're different like styles just
Kasparov was also incredibly tender much
more about the name but ok cousin has
like incredible intuition you know and
you can see that when he plays the last
time he plays he is even more stronger
than than his opponent so here they paid
Bishop d3 citrine of course in many of
the scheme this player has played quite
a few games and they've looked them and
when they look them within understanding
they really know what they are doing so
Bishop f4 or Bishop g4 and okay with
reverse more water we get depletion I
got from Bishop f4 so let's see because
here there are some details with then we
look at at my game and I'll tell you the
differences so Bishop e7 now not Castle
now he plays Bishop h5 in my game I
don't remember if played castaway a6
but still the difference is that so
being a great player plays it better I
mean better you know just to keep the
rook on h8 because you have to play
this exact - is changed now this bishop
and then of course now it's maybe a
little bit early to start with rookie
three because it doesn't make so much
racket pain either I still have not
Castle so here he plays h3 but before
looking at this game let's look at the
other one so I'll show you the next one
after playing this incredible game how
he made an improvement so instead of
paying and she played h4 saving one
temple and I'm showing at the game he
lost this was probably which one okay no
I'll put it like in notation because I
don't remember if I put which game was
really no it was in three minutes past
two seconds so it was obviously after
that game but just let me show you so he
played aged for a six a four
now he's postponing his castle Bishop g5
take with the pawn and now he got
obviously no compensation here for for
the pawn and he got a very huge
advantage after that he made some
mistakes which kept us when he came last
time and even lost the game but he made
even an improvement so the idea of age
for you see it if we continue looking at
at our game let's see let's take a look
let's put this melt and now after that
after we and get some moves I'll try to
to show you because I've put how how
much time used now a four well this is
an important thing that before going to
kiss plan playing on the King site
obviously he just received him here with
a four in my game I didn't even bother
to play a four but maybe he's right
maybe he's right here it makes it
slightly more difficult or for black I
guess although it's it should not be so
much important but it's about pole
structure so probably you know the world
champion really knows like the best way
so I understand it a for from a pressure
point of view it's better just to put
you know this pawn on a four because
late in the game if he plays like b5 and
before it's better you know this poem
just in case for some for the exchange
to be exchanged just in case because if
it's nothing change it always can be can
be a target when the pole is on fo the
best you can do because forget the Queen
when he leaves the Queen site if you
live like definitely when you have a
real attack going on on the kingside so
when the ponies relay for with the piece
we have on the boat
you really can attack it so you can
exchange it you know making b5 in some
moment but then the only weakness you
can get into my queen site will be the
pollen c3 theoretically when the poison
a - for example it can become a weakness
or if you put it on a tricky and become
a 5 B 4 in some moment when it can be
decent dangers for you so his decision
to put the pawn on e4 probably he knows
exactly what he is doing
so I this one detail which I which I've
seen today I had forgotten it she put
the pollen fo but it's better in order
to have these things in your memory just
some files you know for certain chest
patterns just to know 97 still
postponing you know castle but okay how
much you can postpone it Haruki three
okay here I wanted to to tell you what
will be the next move but he already
played it rookie three and here I have
no way before playing rookie three he
played like he thought like ten seconds
which for him maybes no but he was quite
familiar with this person so Rukia tree
obviously the look is waiting for you
and of course how dub on the Alliance
yogi what plan do you have
it's very hard to imagine do have a plan
without short castle now and here for
example we see the great benefit of
playing a Thor because okay
if you cannot play a four maybe I can
start you know be five queen be seven
still not casting but here you don't
have that because I paid a for and you
don't have some you know extensions I'm
grabbing a stay on the Queen side which
should be your playing ground we don't
have that you don't get the be a square
so okay you have to do what you have to
do the castle which is not very well
okay now when you look at it it seems
like okay what was the problem so let's
look at the how greatly he played so now
castle and now the next more
we play you've already seen it so no
doubt about that
h4 here 96 how do we continue well I
hear it still seem that maybe they take
a hold on
but what white play how they continue
how we transfer token h3 we have to move
the knight from F Torino first keep a
squid you know he does not play Knight
e5 here so this is very interesting us
to see how he plays the guy I told the
whole game was played in less than three
minutes so it's third play 95 he he
plays first the move which sooner or
later will be played so the Queen here
on d1 allowing you to play b5 so no
problem with that
and this was played like a cousin
continues playing very fast b5 well this
is your playground you have to get
something before something real Ackerson
it's too late like in my base game he
played in as such not a way which does
not make much sense that ok the whites
attack just build it up very naturally
without here of course we are talking
about one of the best play so we're so
although maybe 97 which you rightly
point out who does not make like yet
impression but he was trying somehow ok
in this game to divert you know the
opener from this 95 now before well ok
now even what what we are talking before
I was giving my my oh dear come here oh
he says no no I I want to keep your palm
on a phone because it can become you
know some kind of a target so it's also
about the speed here if you can very
quickly gather your pieces and start a
take because ok it seemed it is not so
easy because the Knights knife is
controlling the h-drive
it seems like you have to to know just
how to put the pieces just to fluidly
talk to continue and attack something
which when you when we are watching it
doing it which are of course of course
of course but ok it's very difficult
what what mode to play what would you
play here now
please be some chief I interesting
now of course Bishop g5 Tyga's the the
knight on f6 so also tag is the bishop
on e7 you can now exchange
amia to unify because I can even take
her with a pawn on and then you losing
your key material so okay basically if
you look what he is doing it we are
saying over how natural I don't need
anymore the bishop on on f4 because he's
already played before here so why to
control the the BH square no need no
Bishop on g5 Luke h3 yeah how simple
yeah but okay it's different you know
just to play in all displayed instantly
rook e8 now at least you know he defends
the the bishop on e7 now how do we
continue three player okay Street we
exchange on c6 let me show you this
happy played Ragesh 3
because now keep things at okay if you
take me 500 taken H wife is prepared
already
the queen is on d1 everything is
prepared on the position just to go in
Meereen to attack so he does not
consider that it's really 5050 seconds
on this move not not too much no but way
probably in this 15 seconds kick confuse
quite a lot of stuff you know what is
the right but basically I can assure
that it's most about intuition it's
about some calculus but not a big one
it's about feeling what do you feel that
it's like the best move and okay here we
have like the best example Queen c7 now
Queen seven you know challenge is denied
but at least it gives me some time which
is important 9 f3
because now whether you exchange or
after that I exchanged a play 95 I win
some temple 20 seconds on this move
because this is understandable he had a
choice so he have to find which is like
the the right way in this way when he
plays he never has to to consider
something with opponent e3 because when
it was 90 f3
when we exchange it I took with a night
alone the pawn is defended with the ruko
on h3 to get to it with some other
pieces we'll need a lot of rearrangement
and probably because years before you
rearranged or take
Pouncy three you'll get made it so this
is I guess his kiss consideration ninety
three twenty seconds also take take now
Luke t8 how do we continue black is
playing like sensing a wolf int he is
asking okay let me see your attack well
I think the following two moves also he
made them quite quickly because okay not
anything clear immediately I mean some
other way so why not you know just
exchange dick played the other night on
e5 when his one key seeing exactly how
to proceed so he plays here here and now
can he find even to rain forced even his
pieces now or he cares to start an
attack because okay if you play if you
play
let's say h5 and I take with a pawn I'm
not very sure if you take on f6 I take
you take g6 you giving me mate
no I'm defend it on on f7 with the Queen
now here you can play GFO
this is like the most most of us we
think they seem very attractive but he
you know because he's a lot of knowledge
of the occasion he makes him another
move to try to to point out some other
weaknesses of the black pigeon so he
turns out the torso on f7 you have to be
careful so to make h5 even in a better
fashion much more forceful he plays a
move which when we see it seems very
natural but many times we don't play you
know it seems net so when the best
players like Carson which is clearly
number one plays it so what move Queen
f3 no yeah so we have tricky plays Queen
f3 10 seconds on this move obviously for
him it was quite you know understandable
that the Queen should be here no they
said the last moves were played in like
10 seconds for all of them so ok so
quite quite fast
Bishop d8 now a key defense on f7 and
probably it's time for white Oh to get
some action and here of course he
thought but I let's see how he thought
what do you think it why should play
here can they make their patient that
always time to to get something going on
no he decided here that it's time to go
and play age five five seconds on this
one so hip Keating's
the world champion read his pizza in
best position here on tone takes on age
five probably as far as I see it
how-how-how
you should continue after pawn takes
from age five
let's see no I'm looking at let's look
together because here if you take I
think I have not analyzed this but
probably he wants to play okay it's not
he also can play you know now he case he
can play also here with the Queen on f3
I'm looking at it I can take and take
with the with a rock on edge right now
because it's hanging the bishop on f6 so
I'm including now I'm looking at it just
in the board here so I can include such
ideas become the Queen on f3 is quite
beneficial now and take with that with
the rook now if you take on c3 no
problem don't I hope this make or maybe
not maybe Luke h8 is not so I take on c3
maybe it's only continuous now maybe
it's not that I'm looking at this but I
don't see I made maybe because I'm not
so good check check
maybe some ideas with g3 King G to let
let's look at it because ok it's always
better just to look ourselves not to put
like Angeles because during a game we
have to be here I don't see mate no
no he'll take on d4 I don't see maid
here so maybe maybe here and the other
idea which we are talking is quite
natural G for to play here which looks
quite quite unpleasant
well also there is an idea
to be honest like g3 oh I'm hanging here
I can't and okay it's not time for such
artificial look like this is King edge -
okay - and this a little bit something
okay let's see g4 what happens on g4
let's play this move g4 now if you take
with a poem probably you got made it
here no this seems this seems bad but
maybe it's not so bad but it has like a
feeling that it's not very good
do we have some ideas if you take with a
poem what else we can do
[Music]
ah Bishop h6 yeah you can but okay
probably even probably this which which
later I I thought that maybe not maybe
maybe this is it's not bad at all
threatening made know and I was thinking
this but maybe maybe fear you know Kiev
Torino
yeah okay probably this is loss yeah
this should be you can escape because 96
no so it's all right that's why it's
good you know to look on the road not to
look at and to some goals but just Co en
what what are you doing probably here
you how to put it like reasonable now
what do you do because here on this I
can hear a lot of moves and even even
okay probably everything is moving but
on Queenie 7 probably rook takes from f6
now just not to to make the team if it's
a team competition just not to make the
team worried about how that the game
this was a this disa phrase which I'm
saying is from the book of Karpov he was
playing like one beautiful game it was a
maybe Olympiad and he was having a piece
hut after a very beautiful attack
I think against Romanian player and he
plays like Queen d7 exchanging the
Queen's in the comment in the book was
for the team not to worry anymore
that it has the point so that's why I
remembered it this way the carbon was
saying in his book so probably you know
he knows so yeah alright so probably
okay Wesley looked at it just a little
bit because I he was thinking he was
like less than two minutes less time
then because he's under attack everybody
will think here because all the
possibilities does not look beautiful at
all no five-second on this one so and
probably okay you've seen enough of that
so night x1 each I fight I think yeah my
take on h5 how do we continue oh the
first move okay he takes takes now
and it was interesting till the end
because even if the entity become like a
gem I mean the whole game I was
impressed
yeah g4 seems like the most logical no
not too many other ways to do any other
attack no so here no doubt he played him
instantly g4 96 and now now seriously
because we have some possibilities we
can play Queen h1 which does not seem
very nature we can play King G - yeah
pinky - seems more into cartoon style
let's see what he played in g2 no
everything in its place in G toe g5 this
is an interesting move because he'd
neglect the possibility of of g5 no
because it was always hanging so if you
start trying with a king you always have
to consider even g5 ty takes from g6 now
and the pin so so he tries to make like
that and hopes that sometimes the Queen
cannot be on Seto and it happened so he
defended quite well in such a precarious
it has to be said so brilliant play by
by saw but he was just outplayed this
game it happens you know g5 now Queen
III this was also not not the most
obvious move know because you gather you
had a choice but okay now g5 stopped g5
and he wants to run away with the King
so he has to find the best way just to
to keep him into the line of fire if you
double the rooks I start running you
know with the king so black also
defended like I told you earlier
quite quite with a lot of imagination
but away the world champion play that
and now of course you can defend the
pawn we ties okay if he takes with the
Queen on G Phi this is like the end I
mean the end the end so 90 for the is
this to stop the end of the attack
because we he combines like the greatest
player he's like the greatest now we
have he combines everything with like
all this feeling or vision with like
like I told you in the in the previous
time or anyway today the same like cup
of super precision in the spa lines like
these three to three lines like you know
like computer even better sometimes I'll
break everything is well so here what is
the mode how it push away this night
which wants to put some breaks into our
defense but he decided I guess first to
play f3 because what they did a move
will never escape you know so maybe this
is like what I had maybe you can try
just the right combination of the moves
so maybe you'll play route catch one
maybe guidon g5 he is first better so
per safe 3 because if you take on c3
with the Queen you lose a piece and if
you okay if you take with the knight and
the Queen takes from g5 it's it's really
made he takes here now that's key double
so he plays Queen g5 he doubles here so
probably there was not much of a
difference
Queen g5 did I right no this was played
everything very quickly
Queen takes on c3 now also followed
quickly because these moves quite forced
now he cares 340 left now so like you
see until now he was played like
4-minute and something this game which
most of us if we play in a normal game
should be quite happy no takes kill
Queen takes from g7 Quincy to heal he
taught a lot Wesley and found a very
good idea the only one check to control
the g6 and now defense and now he has
like 155 left yeah black and now it was
interesting that maybe this was the
moment yeah this was the moment that the
only moment he thought in the game
really like one minute here he played
very quickly this move rock 8 6 no here
an hour he talk
he talks like one minute obviously he
saw in one second that he can play rook
takes on Isaac's check King takes on
Isaac's Quinn takes on f8 but we have
like one special feature which you
probably have seen in the games you have
played the night normally when the Queen
is very cold the Knights like the
perfect piece to defend because when
Luke takes on Isaac's check King takes
me Quinn texts me
I can play 96 no more checks probably a
win but still a lot of game and he felt
that maybe here there is something
better and he found it in one minute
let's ride together a little bit you
know to to get into his mind and try to
find a frost line which the first move
is very easy to spot but the second move
we have to find some trick so let's
start with the with the checks now when
we looking at first lines no because
okay let's not forget that our queen is
a techno so we can play like a move
let's say like King 996 he'll just take
it now with a queen and okay we can take
queen f8 and forget that the rook is
hanging on g6 and we can even lose the
game which happens to all of us in
having short amount of time in these
games no but here he taught the world
champion thought one minute and here
it's a very good sign of his intuition
not that he just found that and how he
finished the game but he felt that here
there might be something better because
obviously they are aligned he saw it he
merely but after rook takes 26 taken
effect kinetics there is nothing forced
on sign that like I told you I need the
knight in defense well the king and now
the Queen now after one moves the the
back will be threatening to give some
checks with the Queen okay it becomes
you know
waters which are not so clear and you
want clarity in okay he had time and he
in - at this time
advantage of time justify the first move
what is one of the first frost moves
what checks do we have 25 f6 what f6 now
don't forget the piece which is which is
depending on I said no when he was
thinking here I will show it live
I also a few times of talking about what
about a 70 and I saw a guy didn't he can
take it now can you find here the multi
play where I can the Queen go
and I'll give of it with a temple so the
movies is guarding everything and still
threatens I mean well even offers you
let me give you a very important even
offers you an endgame which you can
accept no it offers you an endgame
yeah so he found that in one minute
which really in such a question when you
have options
you know it's impressive that's why I
put this game into my favorite of blades
bit because I hey this is impressive now
queen g6 yeah yeah and and this kind of
money or seen a breezy are very
difficult but the guide taught and ok he
thought there is something better and he
found it he's not winning immediately
because the finish is even more
impressive and of course the finish
after you when you can find such details
it's no surprise that you find the
finish because probably you can find
whenever is on the board so queen g6 one
minute here no way let's let's see it
like with everything Intel to see now
Carson so plate after one minute of dot
Queen g5 of course cool six was paid
humility but before thinking of 25 we
thought like one minute now he goes like
239 left still after this you know and
found it f6 queen g6 Queen a4 check now
this line is also quite beautiful now
let me show here I the guy saw that also
know which which is really impressive
now this is one of the domains which we
see in problems normally no well so of
course waste is also also this hole
didn't want to be because he kill appear
we know the mechanism with this diagram
so he didn't want to appear but still
that the the finish was also impressive
so he played here King d8 and now the
guy taught here yeah less than 30
seconds he had some other options but
okay this is clearly the best move in
less than 30 seconds well but I believe
that if you can find Queen g5 Queen g6
in one minute and you can find almost
everything when you are in such a
incredible for me when you are such a
genius no quindi one with a very good
return made on the last you know file so
this is Quinn d1 and okay now was a
beautiful execution here 96 Oh after
Quinn block you have seen even that you
know check okay just check because of
the fork only move now you have to
actually check and now he resigned
because of the typical of the studies
this is code I know how it's called in
English but I know this code like when
the general scape this kind of a here a
polite so how their code here on their
uniforms so when I give this kind of
mate when your own pieces prevent you
from going left to right they call it in
the in the in the studies in the
composition they stow it like a plate
like may treat a plate so like the
uniform of the general so this is
something like that because it your
piece is standing in the way you know on
the left and right of your own kick and
prevent him from going further no yeah
yeah exactly
and now if you invoke our with the Queen
I still taking still give you a check on
these six is to in one of the pieces now
just not to worry about so yeah this was
like really really impressive
well let me show you now what I've
played today which is very very far away
from this but okay the move order in our
game was like that that's why it was the
same position so we've played that here
oh yeah I mean this is like if you take
when f3 I just take home on busy or no
just in case here here and we have the
same position which I helped the game
here as far as why I painted so probably
I remember it correctly I'm not very
sure if he paid cast away six maybe he
played ia6 I paid rookie one Castle okay
so he is probably prematurely it's
better like Wesley sort of play Bishop a
try Bishop G 695 not the only move but
okay and now you starting or moving the
the the bishop towards the
the rook tour was the king's flank this
move I really don't get it the idea but
it makes some deaf a it square but I
really think this is like a bad move
yeah I don't know if I have to include a
four I placed a forward look here bishop
g6 take take Quinn d1 go gathering some
pieces he took here 97 90 of 3
well cleaning like the way of my queen
so I have to bring peace but ok the
pieces are heading towards here I hit
some problem with it with the mouth
these two so most of the games I like
one minute went for with the win the
mouth but ok this is not an excuse
because of the mistake is not because of
anything because of just playing playing
dead so Bishop f6 I took took okay this
is like here it's a quite easy position
you know to play even in in such a game
so basically you have like a big big
advantage so you have to get the pieces
you can get a rhythm Queen f4 Queen g5
well here I've put off you know but okay
you don't need note which I look at it
just a little bit after the game you can
have you know this kind of attack you
can have Quincy 5 for example takes care
of this square e 7 so you can play 95
and then when he plays King e7 you can
even put the Luke Duke on f7 any even
tie him like g7 Luke 8 7 rubgy 894
threatening rook takes on g7 so he has
to play something in my opinion like
that which is really a rather sad
position well it's not like a force on
the degree it should be made I hear I
didn't play like a bad bad move but this
is like more logical everything is
prepared so bring the pieces and give
him 8 because here one of the most
unfortunate pieces is the rook on d8 so
at least if it was inside one square on
when the Queen go straight for early you
can play Queen Queen on d8 not to
prevent at least two years this square
the rookin d8 is like playing for my
team ok but ok it happens so I play 95
probably not needed but not a bad move
and here is some cyanide ok with the 8
you are not
you're getting in some way wiser but in
many other ways not not too much so I
really when I was a junior and I played
my first in our small countries from the
Balkan Peninsula like there was a
championship coat balcony odda between
Romania Greece Italy and my first
appearance I was like 14 years old
so I played a similar position not we
add our con but similar one after a four
c5 g3 with white and okay in this I just
paid automatically a four and after a
few months I gave him eight I mean he
was a decent player and I was normal
player but still it was very natural so
here I mean not playing ephra shows that
it's not like the only move but shows it
okay with the edge you cannot become
much much you know much improved so f4
is very natural here and then if you
want with the win you can put it like
winning one Queen h4 but therefore is a
move which probably not only Carson but
decent player will play like in one
second but okay here I told it okay it's
over and okay in chess it's never over
especially if you give chance to the
opening so I play not a bad move but
therefore keeps you know everything like
around his neck
but here Queen f4 Knight takes skill
here oblivious like talking I was
talking with Desiree this guy okay now
we give him mate you know it makes like
said impression on not like that I don't
talk so it's very buggy joking and of
course if they take with the Queen on e5
and then still you have attack no very
happy here and just forgetting about
this move and now no mate anymore and
then I played I don't even the rest of
the game is not interesting I play Queen
g5
I don't know him his leg I still got
something I even get at the end winning
endgame we look when I was losing on
time trouble because I get pawned be sad
but still it's I mean not to see details
like that even the other game you know
it makes like a big big difference
because ok you can be too happy and this
is like the essence of the chess game to
happy ok now made made made but no mate
because ok when you only get your horse
on the on the
every piece at least look at the open
case you know some reason or response
because it's really childish to think
that here okay Queen h4 okay you'll take
on g7 you will give him sexy but okay it
didn't happen and this is like one of
the important difference in my in my
opinion but okay when we talk about
about cousin let me just finish with one
of his games when he was like I don't
know if he was 12
one of the first games which one of the
very famous grandmasters like D'Amato
play with him into one of the DS Moscow
opens and only there was like a boy 12
you a boy which like when he after that
or maybe around this age was pressing
Kasparov in a in a major tool games one
of them with white he was come
completely with a big big advantage
let's say no completely winning but by
the words of Kasparov he outplayed him
completely and then the second respond
by chance happen to to to winning to
have one in a half against the calf
against you can see it own new to put a
small boy doesn't so he played with
doumitt of a famous Grandmaster starting
many years with varetsky he and your
super friend so on he was a world
champion three a champion here but he
played one game with a very young cousin
and it was like looking morph in action
because I have won one file with a
casting team games my cross teen like
the most in play there are so many ok
one of them the first one I remember was
this one because of the game of the
dough motive remember reading some intro
was saying okay this is something
incredible I mean this boy very soon
will crush all of them which happened
yeah so it was not like too difficult or
for C 2004 so he was not 14 years so a
little bit all of them then I got but
still very very young so just just look
at the game what happens after that he
played in the same line one active game
with a decent good Grandmaster and of
course he made fun of him I even put
this one in my old bay so this is the
active chest very quick
to show you was like positional lecture
so this one with with okay let me just
find it this one with Argentinian
Grandmaster if I have it although I want
to show just alright this is a little
bit later so okay here info and after
ten years when he was like a
well-established number one he played in
rated game with Rodriguez from Uruguay a
very good tactical tactical Grandmaster
and very good player and it was like you
know positional lecture in 20 moves he
was ready to resign so just first this
one and first you know the de young
cousin and this was in rapid chess here
night III dude da Matta falls in normal
chess so here
no he played Knight f6 let me show you
96 take here d4 so okay so you see many
exceptional inches so now him playing
our time with the pole because he think
that he'll be able to exploit your light
squares and also he think that the time
the temple the temple he has given you
he'll be given it back because when I
offer you exchange of the light squares
you you have to to lose a temple
getting your bishop in a some kind of a
not very good position losing this
temple back in giving in that and also
if we exchange it who you got your light
squares in the problems on the e-file so
it has some logic Queen d7 93 be some
delay now he does not want to exchange
it but okay you'll see the consequence
is d5 making sure that you have some
white holes in your position take a
three no it was like very easy win for
Carson not as impressive as the other
one with the motto but it was like you
know like easy play we've seen that even
before xx movie on the hitting move we
can say that black is completely lost
with a knight on a six now and the rest
was just
so no no fight at all but okay this one
with with D'Amato I want to show you he
5 because D'Amato in 2004 was where he
is now also the who many as a coach of
the Russia I played against Russia when
he was coaching Russia I have very good
memories of that especially of because
I've played this just a curious effect
it's not I have not won a game I played
three times but okay I paid three times
against Russia one was very just to tell
you this is true it's a curious practice
don't have any important but I always
enjoy it like the effect because it will
not change so I played three times
against Russia one time wasn't on my
first Olympia in 94 with Kasparov
kramnik I paid with fiddler in buried
and it was a great pleasure on Moscow in
the center of Moscow to crush Russia in
the whole team to be gathered but there
but their coach in just to give them a
very bad lecture although they won't
Olympia to at the end yeah they want a
limp you but Rick has power of God made
you can see this game by top off with
white on the seventh rank we to talks
after like 25 moves so it was a crushing
defeat I was better with Svidler key off
at the draw with white and ok so I
played three times against Russia and we
had 3-0 against Russia I will not play
anymore with Russia disease for sure so
it will stay forever some of other
players about him plates amount of time
and they lost so I'm the only one who
played three times and three times row
so it will not change it does not get
any important but ok at least it stays
so ok it was very good to any we played
with Russia when when I was playing
although I get to repeat I I made two
draws with dragon safe which we did and
one having a very good kitchen I have
one loss and we want this with two
aniket when I have against good cook
yeah like I played well but I get a very
good position but then I'm straight in
because this was the only only appeared
the last one which I really prepared to
the limping I paid French which I almost
never played in my life so I prepared
like a new opening and we shook I got a
good patient that have that played badly
and the guy crushed me with a win an
attack quite deservedly so
so we 593 96 take
and now we see again this motive so it
it was quite familiar with Carson the
second game we saw 10 years after death
to play in this position you know d4 and
to put you know accent on on development
and mainly on the fact that it's not
very easy to find like a safe place for
for your king
now we have some here I've commented
some lines theoretical but let's look at
the game because it's a real gem Queen
d4 well he's happy to give you the pawn
on c4 he plays Bishop g4 just like
morphia no problem and just like fish
area here in 96
no matter of course don't want with
which 14 years boat you know to take
some pawns in to get into history
he told here we better stay out of
history but he get you know just right
into into it but away for his
justification now he can be proud of
this game because now Carson is a world
champions okay Bishop g5 b5 Bishop e3
but very natural play Bishop e7 and see
his piece every one of them is
participating now on d5 he can play rook
h1 and there is okay just my commands
here on d5 trying to block the pieces
here there is this double attack many
times we all mentioned that I already
talked with you it this is one of the
most used weapons inches the double
attack like the most effective here
touching the pair bishop just to be sure
that you open and does not enjoy the
pair of bishops you know just in cases
not after the game say I had the pair of
Bishops so you will one of them just
never to boss with his parachute just in
case know he played Queen d7 dome at of
rocky one now the problem which I put in
my accommodate on lon Castle you have
problems with G for now so the square
the square e six if you move the bishop
and if you take there is hanging pieces
on the on the on the a line like this
line okay justice always good now here
here the type of lines which even from
very early age
Carson was seeing quite precisely to the
end always so here King T eight out of
necessity I mean here everything is
so it's you it may be strange for you to
say don't model such a good grandmother
play King yet well when when you see him
play King date it's not because the life
is very good no it's because the wife
gets become so you see that a long
castle there is g4 and on d5 there is
simple taken now and now everything
crushes you know he begins to take
everything and so King yet let's try to
to run away but okay that the easiness
which is key he developed the attack is
really mind-blowing Luke takes 27 just
like you are watching the game of of
Norfolk exactly Luke takes 27 now he
took with the Queen but if he takes with
the king check here okay I mean if you
play Cantrell just take on f6 now
everything is hanging here check and
just in case no simple chess but very
very effective
Queen takes 27 Queen f4 we just talked
about the most efficient chess weapon
taro attack you know touching on d6 + f5
now there is no way to save the game
well just let's see this line take where
do we go now I can even take on yeah I
take on c6 oh no I can even on on King
c8 how do we win in the in the simplest
way Bishop f6 Bishop e6 yeah and also on
Queen e1 we can care about ways we can
even car with a temper of the one if we
want
even with this here and it's the end so
here
Bishop d7 oh maybe this is like the
interesting I should give your dog a
let's just look at the game 94 well
really like how the chest should should
be play you know because we hear like
the the the sad impression and the big
difference because white is playing with
more pieces
because without doing really the a 18 on
h8 well basically watching you know the
black patient getting destroyed 94 d5 96
well now it's all oh yeah this this is
also complete fiasco just something like
that you know everything hanging oh yeah
ever he could have resigned here but I
really played like a chicks only move
here g5 24 and healed the 19 move
against the 14 about he resigned but
okay he resigned because where he didn't
want you know to look at this position
so this is you know what we had like in
potential like the world champion it's
very good that not only he realized that
what he realized many many more things
like everything he could handle so it's
really for me to to real I like for us
it we have such a world champion if you
can display so many aspects of chasing
it really moves forward the game so I
believe it you know almost every game
you you touch of Kim you can always
learn something that's why when I
started many years ago to look at his
game of looking you know for his young
age and you always found a very
incredibly mature chasing and versatile
I mean everything could be done well and
okay at least always when you look at me
we can learn a lot of these things and
try to to improve on them okay I I hope
you enjoyed it and will continue like
the next times and okay we all look oh
so with some other players not posting
as it's only Carson because there are a
lot of a lot of incredible players and
we can always look at some good things
and to enjoy them so thank you for today
and the eraser
you
[Music]